that's one right there I look Bob take
this walk to the liquor store you going
it's not even noon tell you something
whether the water swirls clockwise or
counterclockwise [ __ ] is going down I
need you to remember that see you at the
liquor store
dan
I gotta let that marinate oh well you
got vision
you will need eyesight my bull let that
marinate
let that marinate the only difference
between me and you and you is the letter
M E and the letters y ou you let that
marinate
if recreation is a recreation then who
invented happiness let that marinate
I'm afraid it
let's see my office
mental illness like he it will mentally
like he ill on some other [ __ ] dad I
could see some early early symptoms
delusions of grandeur hallucinations
disorganized thoughts for example it's
90 degrees outside and you're wearing a
very large jacket it looks like the heat
don't affect you when you got ice in
your veins son right actually I'm a
doctor I don't mean nothing he's a
revolutionary so what are you Kenny in
the world professionally you have the
most schizophrenia that I have ever seen
in my entire career yo you ain't on
nothin man you lyin see you lying son
Elias sealion more like sausage dog he a
schizophrenic let that marinate
delusions of grandeur nation what is the
distinction between the shoes I own and
the shoes of a judge if you play your
cards right you could end up in a
medical journal I don't know what we're
gonna do help me